hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast era just check it in on you
oh I'm just shallow happy turkey day to
you
oh you know stuffing and potatoes and
pie and beer cranberries and gravy and
your cousin who's gay um hey what's
going on how are you happy Thanksgiving
happy not having to [ __ ] go to work
today huh
you around the table are you sitting
down yet well if you haven't gone
downstairs yet I got some advice for you
today it's gonna be a day I think
there's gonna be a lot of [ __ ]
arguments a lot of [ __ ] arguments at
the table right the big [ __ ] election
some people wanted the guy with the
eyebrows some people wanted the [ __ ]
leg with the pantsuit right this is what
you gotta do see you're already gonna
have a fight right there's already gonna
be your older brother there's gonna be
this person there's gonna be another
four somebody's gonna say something
right and you're gonna be you're gonna
have a couple of wild [ __ ] turkeys as
you standing over there you know eating
a [ __ ] appetizer or two somebody's
gonna be getting on your nerves maybe
somebody's [ __ ] wife who won't shut
the [ __ ] up
right why the [ __ ] did he marry her
maybe maybe it's the husband Jesus
Christ what is she doing with this guy
all he does his [ __ ] talk about
himself something's gonna drive you up
the [ __ ] wall if it's not this it's
gonna be that it says this is the phrase
this is a phrase that's gonna say good
day okay save the whole [ __ ] day cuz
you're not gonna change anybody's
opinion all these [ __ ] jerk-off still
yelling huh could you vote for Trump
well what the [ __ ] about Hillary you're
not changing you're just gonna [ __ ]
yell at each other so here's the phrase
you gotta use to get through this
[ __ ] day
all right along with the alcohol
whatever drug you [ __ ] want to use
just fair enough you know hey fair
enough
it's like that's all you got it to what
you say hey hey guys guys guys fair
enough fair enough whatever you don't
need to see him anymore
right now if you're younger and you
still live there that's kind of [ __ ]
tough I don't know what to tell you but
if you've already moved out of the house
why are you still arguing with these
people why you still trying to change
their [ __ ] minds
you're not gonna change their minds all
right I don't give a [ __ ] if you majored
in debating it's just stupid [ __ ]
school in the woods whatever the [ __ ] it
is you did that now you're coming back
and now you think you know something and
you think that your [ __ ] siblings
want to hear it you know what they don't
the same way you don't want to hear the
way they [ __ ] eat when they've had a
couple two three right and all of a
sudden the man everything just sounds
like they're eating [ __ ] mashed
potatoes you know you start having these
murderous [ __ ] thoughts you know just
fair enough hey hey fair enough whatever
whatever was that what you think is that
it's how you look at the world hey god
bless you pass the [ __ ] peas and
carrots fair enough fair enough
you know and that's all you got to do
eventually the meals gonna be over all
right and you're gonna get in your
[ __ ] car you're gonna drive away
unless you stay in there for the weekend
well then you got to go out to God oh no
you got to we got oh right you got to
get the [ __ ] out of there yeah
Thanksgiving is a it's such a great day
there's no pressure to get any gifts
eating a bunch of great food all of that
is tremendous okay unless unless you go
into her [ __ ] family's house or his
family's house that's a weird one
because you know you're used to all your
family's food and Thanksgiving you know
how it's supposed to taste then you're
gonna go somewhere else it's gonna taste
a little bit different you know this is
like a classic stand-up bit like here's
how it usually is but when you [ __ ]
blah blah blah it's a whole different
story right then you just gotta suck it
up and just be like you know worst case
scenario this absolutely [ __ ] sucks
you know
in which case fair enough you know you
don't know how to cook
okay you're supposed to cook today you
know it's like when it's somebody's
birthday most people can't sing but
goddamn it you got to sing the song so
they do the best they can
happy birthday right they do what the
[ __ ] they can well sometimes you got to
take the same [ __ ] theory of a
tone-deaf person singing happy birthday
to you because they love you right you
get you gotta apply that to food which
is a [ __ ] which brings it to how
do I make it look like I ate this [ __ ]
when I really didn't well oh Jesus I
don't know how to do this one what you
gotta do is you gotta [ __ ] you got to
engage in a lot of conversation as you
just sort of [ __ ] hitting the plate
with your fork a little bit as if you
almost like you know that noise people
make when they want someone to make a
speech that annoying [ __ ] thing you
know oh my god nothing [ __ ] makes my
goddamn blood boil like when I'm in the
middle of a [ __ ] conversation that
some [ __ ] starts hitting a glass with
the fork and then for whatever social
[ __ ] reason I have to now shut up you
know oh my god that gets me going but
not today not today everybody hey fair
enough Hey somebody's down somebody's
down the [ __ ] Street over there with
a little [ __ ] Spode knocking it
against some glass you know I guess we
all have to stop as adults we have to
shut the [ __ ] up right like we're
working for this [ __ ] babe you know
what ain't fair enough fair enough
you know you just [ __ ] sit there oh
oh here we go
oh good no here's a clichéd what I'm
thankful for speech oh is that what you
thankful for you know I'm thankful for a
lady every [ __ ] word that comes out
of your mouth is one less it was one
word closer to the end of whatever the
[ __ ] it is you're saying you know that's
what you know it's you know the
passive-aggressive move is when
someone's in the middle of that is you
[ __ ] as somebody just kind of pointed
somebody it pointed some plate you know
a little [ __ ] give me that but
they're still yammering on you know you
know back in 1983 when we first saw this
house
right you just sitting there butter and
you [ __ ] roll oh is this [ __ ]
gonna go every goddamn year from 1983
hey you know what fair enough fair
enough yeah I didn't want to wear this
sweater right he's [ __ ] have these
potatoes instant these [ __ ] potatoes
hey fair enough
hey you didn't you didn't have time to
[ __ ] cook real ones maybe they ran
out of book down there was the last
[ __ ] time they ever ran out of
potatoes they never run out of potatoes
in this country it's why so many [ __ ]
Irish people over here right [ __ ]
Irish man they tapped out on their own
country one [ __ ] time in their whole
history they run out of potatoes and
everybody [ __ ] jump ship right but
not the real Irishmen the real Irishmen
and real ladies they [ __ ] stuck
around
I like these cowards that all move to
[ __ ] New Jersey but you know what a
fair enough
you know they wanted some potatoes this
is one of these days people you know and
if you're younger man you got to enjoy
the holidays cuz cuz they're never gonna
get it doesn't get better then you know
cuz you don't know any better so the
food tastes the way the [ __ ] food is
supposed to taste in your world right
everyone who's supposed to be there is
there you know it's when you get old and
you start expanding your [ __ ] world
and all of a sudden you know Jesus
Christ I mean you're sitting there with
somebody you might even me up me might
be sitting at that [ __ ] table being I
don't know if I'm with the right person
right now
what the [ __ ] of my day you know what
say what be fair enough I'm with
somebody that I probably was never
really in love with but didn't realize
what love was you know and now here I am
and all I gotta do is not get in an
argument for one [ __ ] day I can do
this right
by Saturday I'm gonna be out of this
[ __ ] relationship and you know what
oh I'm gonna be thankful then you bet
your sweet [ __ ]
oh my god if it starts going into
politics if it starts going into
politics you almost need like a referee
during this period of US history to just
literally step in with one of those
footlocker [ __ ] athlete's foot refs
shirts blow a [ __ ] whistle and just
send the two people two opposite [ __ ]
lazy boys let it go let it soak so she
went home she went home it's over okay
she's not coming back I don't think
she's got a third run in her all right
sir sit up sit up sit out a buddy
nobody's building a wall today
okay just [ __ ] relax maybe he could
be the peacemaker who knows who the [ __ ]
knows I'm actually very excited you
wouldn't know it this year for
Thanksgiving cuz I'm back in my house
the kitchen is done oh my god [ __ ]
kitchen is unbelievable my lovely wife
[ __ ] freaked when she saw it she
wasn't looking at it you know she says
like I just want to see it when it's
done I want to see it when it's done
I didn't I was peeking at the presents
the whole time ruining my Christmas but
outside it makes somebody that makes
sure that [ __ ] was looking all right
right so uh she got to see it from
basically a gutted kitchen to just BAM
right there Fred a [ __ ] brand-new
kitchen and it's absolutely gorgeous the
people who built it you know what that's
what I'm thankful for the people who
[ __ ] built it man it's like I can't
believe that that thing is in my house
and I get to go in there and make myself
a little leg over AG this morning was
some bacon and all that by the way I
bought that [ __ ] grill top
I bought that lit [ __ ] griddle thing
last night and Nia's pissed at me sort
of you wait I'm gonna make a one
grand-slam breakfast all right watch
your shut the [ __ ] up a little bit of
[ __ ] hashbrowns some [ __ ] bacon
right just like the bacon over you
cooked the [ __ ] eggs and the grease
of the bacon like nobody can handle that
I don't know why the [ __ ] we have
Guantanamo Bay all those [ __ ] people
down there if you want him to talk you
just make him a Grand Slam breakfast
with the eggs cooked in the grease from
the bacon
and just be like hey buddy not for
nothing I don't know what people told
you but this right here this is America
okay welcome she's gotta answer a couple
of questions here I don't know what the
[ __ ] I'm talking about it's early out
here give me a [ __ ] break
all right what do you want from me okay
you don't like the park yet say guess
what fair enough fair enough
I get it it's plenty other podcast hey
you enjoy go go to all things comedy
wonderful podcast network go check out
Ari Shaffir skeptic tank you know the
Bert Kreischer podcast I don't what the
[ __ ] names of them are what am i what
am i these but [ __ ] encyclopedia
podcasting over here yeah there's gonna
be a lot of arguments today and it'll be
a victory if you know if you don't get
anyone maybe you could be that person
that keeps everybody out of it is
everybody starts screaming yelling you
know you know he's a [ __ ] sex
offender blah blah blah well she's a
[ __ ] and all that type of [ __ ] you
can be in the background like just walk
right in the middle of it oh man I want
to see a compilation of YouTube videos
of the political [ __ ] I've almost
said discourse that's probably the wrong
[ __ ] word do you realize how many
[ __ ] words I know that I don't even
know what the [ __ ] they mean I just know
what words they go with you know
discourse goes with political political
discourse you know you use the word
ornate when you're in a theater I don't
know what it means you know I remember
you know I got a computer I can look at
I hate fair enough I could look it up
why am I gonna bore you guys with this
[ __ ] so when he was I'm back in my house
and one of the great things about being
back in my house is when I get back to
my house okay I get back to all my
sports packages okay I got the [ __ ]
Santa rice package not bragging I'm
thankful for it you know I have it you
don't hate fair enough come on over
right I get the [ __ ] in NBA 1 I know
what it's called I just watched the
Celtics to me it's the Celtics Network i
watch the first half yesterday we're
doing all right against the [ __ ]
Brooklyn Nets you know I think it's cool
they moved to Brooklyn that place when
they were in New Jersey I was just sad
it was just a sad [ __ ] place you know
maybe not for the Devils but for the
nets it was [ __ ] sad you know admit
it New Jersey people you never had love
for him you know then that's where like
that foreign exchange student who never
[ __ ] went home you know or whatever
you adopted a kid cuz you thought it was
a good idea you know you saw one of
these [ __ ] out here doing it yeah
that guy will do it
[ __ ] it we'll take him on what do they
ever do to you yeah some good years Oh
Jason kid I'm sorry from [ __ ] knocking
his halls around my mouth I've had this
[ __ ] coffee for goddamn I don't know
like two [ __ ] weeks you know cuz my
wife with the condition she's in she's
[ __ ] always hot so she's got the
goddamn a/c going and it just dries out
my throat I've never been someone I
[ __ ] hate air conditioning unless
it's like 9,000 [ __ ] degrees out then
I like it other than that I don't like
sleeping you know feeling like I'm
camping in my goddamn house you know I
like it like you know nice [ __ ] you
know 70 71 degrees I need a seven that
first numbers got to be a seven like The
Price is Right
you know let's see that seven right you
start getting into the sixes I wake up
the next day I'm stuffy I got a [ __ ]
mind my throat's killing me
I don't know and I'll tell you people
speaking of killing me I've been I'm
starting to begin the building of my new
hour and obviously having a kid's gonna
be a whole new angle for me but the kids
not here yet so I just been up on stage
just [ __ ] throwing [ __ ] against the
wall and last night I went up did like
12 minutes nothing from my other act and
I just Jesus Christ you want to talk
about just feeling like you have nothing
just being punched out and
I actually have some leftover [ __ ] I
could have probably done but whatever I
did all right I did it right went down
there with the friend of mine just
[ __ ] knocking out new [ __ ] we'll see
we'll see my specials coming out in
January so I'm hope and I have a very
inspirational December actually that's
not true because I don't really I don't
have any rode gigs until February and oh
do I have some [ __ ] rode gigs we're
putting together one and [ __ ]
Charlotte and I know what you thinking
like dude you were just [ __ ] there
I'm gonna be doing the club there
because the following day I'm going to
do Carolina oh yeah
go [ __ ] yourselves I'm gonna go see
Coach K at Duke can't [ __ ] wait it's
gonna be [ __ ] crazy absolute
legendary legendary but you know I got
to get my college hoop [ __ ] games
going here yeah I saw in the end I said
University Indiana so Hoosiers who by
the way would they [ __ ] lose to the
other day
like Indiana regional technical
something or other it's their first
[ __ ] win of any goddamn ranked team
ever
I really should know that name I
apologize that I don't I saw my adopted
college team Kansas I don't know if they
won their tournament I was watching a
little bit of that Wisconsin when I
watched the the semi-finals when
Wisconsin beat Georgetown and I missed
the final which was Wisconsin versa
you went see cuz I went out and I was
doing my homework last night and but I'm
a Jayhawks fan I don't even know why I
always wanted to go to their [ __ ] the
Fieldhouse whatever the [ __ ] they call
it that's a bucket list thing for me I
went to an Indiana Hoosier game way back
in the day when Bobby Knight was still
there the year Michigan State won the
won the title early 2000s I went there
and I scalped a student ticket and I was
so [ __ ] excited than when I got to
the gate the guys looking at me I'm at
that point I was like [ __ ] in my 30s
and [ __ ] right so the guys looking at me
like dude you not a student and I was I
I had nothing that's what come on [ __ ]
all right get in
I remember when that came out of my
mouth I was like gonna [ __ ] I'm not
getting in come on that's all you had
you didn't go with I'm a graduate
student or I got that Brad Pitt disease
from that [ __ ] movie he did with
taraji P Henson remember when he geek
came out as an old baby I would tell you
this story when I watched that movie how
much I annoyed the woman in front of me
there's a scene in there when this dude
is trying to [ __ ] this chick and the
[ __ ] old baby won't shut the [ __ ] up
and I forget what he said but the look
on his face was basically like lady if
you don't get that 80 year old baby the
[ __ ] out of here I swear - I was [ __ ]
crying laughing you know typical
comedian it was supposed to be this
really heavy emotional moment that's
supposed to bring tears and instead I
don't know if you're a comedian it just
it just makes you laugh your ass off
because when I'm what am I going to
let's [ __ ] sitting there crime and a
goddamn mall I'll cry about that I'll
cry then I'm in a mall I'm not gonna
[ __ ] cry while in a mall watching a
movie right so maybe I should have maybe
that's what the [ __ ] wrong with me
but anyways I'm so I'll be watching I'll
be talking about the Bruin I watched I
did watch the Bruins verse the [ __ ] will
be playing I know we got Ottawa how do
you watch a goddamn game he can't
remember who the [ __ ] they played all I
know his jaw went down in the second
period it was one to nothing
that was one oh it's like the Blues my
adopted West Western Conference [ __ ]
team that's right it was one to one then
it was to one us than to two them right
when Chara went out that's what it
started [ __ ] going downhill ended up
being four to a nice [ __ ] home loss
you know was great I [ __ ] put on the
center ice package they're like the
Bruins that a nice [ __ ] winning
streak yeah cuz old freckles [ __ ] put
it on anyways what the [ __ ] am I talking
about here I got it I got Rita Lou
there's a lot of advertising so I gotta
break this up this week hey break it up
huh break it up all right
oh Jesus Christ can anybody tell me how
to pronounce this [ __ ] thing oh oh
[ __ ]
endo Chino Indochina Indochina oh this
is a sting read all right
I know is one of the largest
made-to-measure men's brands they're
making it easy for men to get great
fitting high-quality suits and shirts at
an incredible price
how does it work visit indochina dot-com
or drop by one of their nine North
American showrooms well geez that's
pretty exclusive huh nine is 50 states
pick from hundreds of fabrics and
patterns
well this is like you're going to see
Jimmy the gent I'm gonna go pick out a
suit down the alley choose your custom
customizations from a plough lapels
depletes to jacket linings and more
submit your body measurements kickback
[ __ ] that submit your body measurements
the other in the S for your social
security number no they're not like that
they do that in the United States of
America not in Indochina kick back relax
and get ready to step into the best most
stylish suit you've ever worn in just
four weeks this week my listeners can
get any premium Indochina suit Indo
Chino for just 389 bucks
Indo chido calm when entering BRR at
checkout get 50% off the regular price
for a made to [ __ ] magic premium suit
plus the shipping is free that's
Indochina dot-com promo code BIR IND och
Ino India November Delta Oscar Charlie
Hotel India November Oscar dot-com and
don't China for any premium suit for
just 389 for free shipping Indochina
also has amazing holiday deals right now
they lift up your beard so we can
measure your neck you old prick holiday
deals right now on their shirts and
pants and other products too you'll
never have to worry about badly fitting
suits or expensive tricks two trips to
the tailor again get ready to look like
a million bucks or at least ten grand
who wouldn't take 10 grand all right you
wouldn't know I haven't had a cigar in
[ __ ] weeks
all right legacy box off the most
legendary piece of [ __ ] ass out there
legacy box when was the last time you
watched your home movies if you like
most Americans there's a box in your
closet of videotapes film reels and
photos that don't get watched or take it
out worse they're actually deteriorating
well that's scary that's good now they
got me scared now I want to get this
introducing legacy box a simple and
affordable way to get your recorded
moments digitally preserved on DVD or a
thumb drive can I do a little aside here
I think I speak for everyone when you
have that porno you're made with your
girl that you don't know where it is
just make sure you look at this [ __ ]
before you send it to these [ __ ]
people or a legacy box is gonna take a
whole nother meaning there all right
here's how it works load no pun intended
legacy box with your old tapes film
pictures and audio recordings and send
it back you'll get what go load lega
don't send the [ __ ] thing back you'll
get it back in a couple of weeks on DVD
or a convenient thumb drive ready to
watch share and relive this is so
perfect if nobody knows who the [ __ ] you
are I can't do this because I'd love to
do this with all my old stand-up tapes
but I know that they would end up on
[ __ ] YouTube and I cannot have that
alright legacy box takes care of
everything it provides updates at every
step of the process that's why over
250,000 families have used them The
Huffington Post Parents magazine USA
Today and the view are all talking about
legacy box that's cuz they getting paid
to even Disney has trusted legacy box to
digitize their media
oh speaking of a company that's got to
make sure that they don't send the wrong
porno over there those [ __ ] animals
good lord who knows what they did with
one of the Cory's and for a limited time
go to Laci box.com slash bar to get 40%
40% discount on your order on your order
off your order you should say that's
legacy box.com / / legacy box.com / /
with everyone gathered for the holidays
now is the tonight the perfect time to
share all those old photos cassettes and
home videos go to legacy box comm / burn
now to get 40% discount on your legacy
box alright
why is every [ __ ] company so
different difficult to pronounce alright
this is C so C so leave me alone alright
C so is a place for comedy they won't
tell you how amazing they are but
evidently I will see so is amazing see
that you see that I just [ __ ] I lived
up to my commitment its comedy for nerds
by comedy nerds C so spelt SE eso is the
new ad free streaming service bringing
you hilarious original series
hand-picked classics weeks of stand-up
specials and more bendable comedy
anytime anywhere at sea though they have
weeks of stand-up specials they've been
and I have my [ __ ] specials because I
didn't get a [ __ ] die every episode
of SNL holy [ __ ] ever including new
episodes the day after they air The
Tonight Show Starring Jimmy Fallon The
Late Late Night with Seth Meyers
the day after air and they even have
classics like 30 rock and recreation or
Parks and Recreation and Saved by the
Bell
Jesus Christ this is an amazing place
even British comedies like the original
and the best as far as I'm concerned
office with Ricky Gervais Saul that
dangerous guy who does the Emmys he's
drinking a beer oh what's gonna happen
he's back what's he gonna do this time
probably what he did the first two times
that's why you keep retiring him
rehiring rehiring all right the entire
Monty Python catalog the IT Crowd and
Steve Coogan as Alan Partridge
discovered the next big big names in
comedy and watch the icons before they
make it big like louis c.k what he had
here chelsea peretti
amy [ __ ] shoe bo burnham and so many
more that's [ __ ] hilarious those last
three started like [ __ ] 10 years
after me and they're talking him like
they're these old grizzled vets how
[ __ ] old am i critically acclaimed
originals and exclusive content like
Harmon quest created by comedian Dan
Harmon well that's very modest of
and funny as hell a variety show
featuring comedians such as Jim Jeffries
and Hannibal Buress if you're serious
about comedy you got to try see so
stream at any time alright we get it the
[ __ ] am I doing here see so is ad-free
you already said that for just three
ninety-nine a month right now my
listeners can try see so for free for
two months when you use the promo code
burr at checkout can I use it - I want
to see every [ __ ] episode of SNL 40
plus years of SNL see sells the place
but you get it we get it just go to see
so calm right now and sign up for two
months with the promo code burr and
check out that see SOCOM promo code burr
alright I'll give you a break here for
my [ __ ] reading out loud so anyways
I've been playing drums like a [ __ ]
lunatic been playing two hours a day for
almost every day I missed yesterday
because it was a day before [ __ ]
Thanksgiving we had to run around go get
some [ __ ] oh I didn't mention yeah so
this year I'm not I'm not having we're
not having Thanksgiving here despite the
fact you know we have a brand new
kitchen we were planning to [ __ ] have
people over and then what happened every
all of a sudden a couple people dropped
out everything went out the window and
then we had to scramble now we got all
this [ __ ] food but whatever I got the
grill top covered I'll [ __ ] cook it
later we're actually calling an audible
and we're going over some friends house
which is perfect you know because we're
traveling the day of so most people
aren't gonna be on the [ __ ] road
they're already there you know I already
get into an argument cuz they didn't
listen to this podcast didn't know
enough to be like hey Matt fair enough
fair enough
hey is that what you think god bless you
for thinking that you think that and I'm
not gonna change you from thinking that
but I don't need to think what you think
and you know what all I have to do is
eat with you today that's it then I'm
gonna walk into the [ __ ] living room
you know like going there to watch the
football game oh [ __ ] are you watching
the Westminster Dog Show instead of the
football hey hey fair enough fair enough
you'd like to watch a bunch of clean
poodles prancing around you know I don't
get it
but you get it you got here first
whatever whatever you got a vagina you
run things even though you always say
you don't
okay go ahead do it yeah yeah oh my god
look at that giant float oh my god
remember Bullwinkle of course of course
I do um anyways we're going to a
friend's house and all I have to do is
just bring the [ __ ] liquor and then
I'm good to go
Nia's bringing over a tray of [ __ ]
mac and cheese and that's it and then
we're gonna go over there we're gonna
eat have a good [ __ ] time
I'll fair enough my way through the
whole [ __ ] party I'll get my goddamn
car I Drive home no leftovers no [ __ ]
munching away putting on a ton of
goddamn weight you know perfect [ __ ]
perfect so anyway so I've been I've been
playing drums like a [ __ ] lunatics
but yesterday you know I got all these
nieces and nephews and [ __ ] I got a buy
him some [ __ ] toys and you know so I
was out there buying you know just I
don't know a bunch of goddamn [ __ ] and
uh I don't know god help the [ __ ]
people that go in Friday you know it's
too late to tell you guys this but you
know you know if you don't have money
you got to go out on Friday right you
got to get that forty percent off that
[ __ ] thing that's not even gonna be
there then you get the store and
everything else is regular price right
you got to get out there you literally
have to risk getting [ __ ] trampled to
go get the next goddamn Gameboy a flip
phone whatever the [ __ ] it is your kid
wants you know next year why don't you
like you know there's two ways you can
this three ways you can deal with Black
Friday okay one all right save up some
[ __ ] money you know buy some less
expensive gifts shoplift
you know shoplift on a day that isn't
Black Friday or maybe you want to do it
on Black Friday because then you can
[ __ ] you got the cover of everybody
getting stampeded they're not gonna
realize you know you got a hibachi
underneath you're [ __ ] it there you
go ladies this is what you do you buy
some [ __ ] maternity wear okay then
you put a [ __ ] Abacha underneath it
oh my god you know how many months are
you
holy [ __ ] is that an Audi right what
that's the handle sorry anyways
okay so that's one way of doing it your
second way is if you know you're gonna
go down there all right what you got to
do you got to do a lot of squats okay
and I take a little bit of jiu-jitsu
because you know you know the fights
going to the floor okay and don't
practice on those [ __ ] rubber mats
that they have in the dojos all right
you want to get on a nice [ __ ] little
linoleum floor okay so when you skip the
hip and you try to [ __ ] turn them
over like it's gonna be a different
surface now if you've been practicing on
on one of those AMF mats like all of a
sudden you're on the floor you know it's
gonna you you might you know you might
throw out your hip trying to slide on
that thing all right I would definitely
add some weights a lot of big girls a
lot of big girls show up big girls show
up on [ __ ] Black Friday all right
there's a lot of weight there so maybe I
take a little Aikido I'd learn how to
use their [ __ ] you know all that all
that physics coming at you is that right
word whatever the [ __ ] is all that
weight you just got to have it passed
right through you like water that's what
they always say right in Asian culture
you got to be like water you know oh is
that what I got to do I don't do it I
can never touch my [ __ ] toes the way
you're doing it right now I'm not like
water okay I'm like the cup that holds
the [ __ ] water so how about that all
right I know
water can drown you and I know that
water can [ __ ] you know you know
takes the form of whatever shape it's
poured into but would you like to me to
smash this [ __ ] Cup over your head
yeah I didn't think so
so being a cup okay or a [ __ ] salsa
also okay I interrupt it I'm sorry you
know what hey hey kung fu master Jedi
guy hey fair enough fair enough I'll
become water no the [ __ ] I got it what
he gonna do huh we won't want I got to
hold a couple of [ __ ] orders of food
here say bend over at the waist
gradually stretching my hammies is that
what the [ __ ] I'm supposed to do dude
it's your [ __ ] world whatever you
want me to do here okay there's that
option and I guess I said there's three
option you what the third options could
be you could just say I don't observe
the [ __ ] holidays you know by the way
shout out to all the Jewish people today
you know they always get left out of
Thanksgiving because of their religion
they don't celebrate it you know what I
mean they just they don't
I was trying to say that I said it to
Nia yesterday right and I kind of
mind-fucked her because I said it really
quick saying Jewish people did not
celebrate Thanksgiving you know
obviously it's Christmas but you know
it's the holidays you know if you're not
Jewish like you have a vague
understanding of everybody else's [ __ ]
religion right you know there's a day
you know you know there's a couple of
challah with Jewish people you know
there's a couple of day offs we get
because of their religion in September
all right
or at least days we don't have to try as
hard and then there's a day they Chinese
food which is I believe Christmas or is
it I think it's Christmas right I don't
know what the [ __ ] they do on New Year's
nobody [ __ ] knows so if you're not
Jewish you can throw [ __ ] out like that
so I just throw out the NIA go and like
we're in the grocery store I said you
know what let's take time to to give
thanks you know and pray for all those
Jewish people that don't celebrate
Thanksgiving and then she just goes that
isn't remotely true or somebody was
trying to do the math on her head I
figure out the [ __ ] she said and I died
laughing I was like you had zero
confidence in that right now and then
she thought about she does nothing sense
of fights about [ __ ] given thanks
everybody celebrates it right except for
Isis
any terrorist listen listener do you
guys have a Thanksgiving what do you
guys give thanks for huh I can't go down
that [ __ ] road that's gonna be too
goddamn politically incorrect
that's something late night at a comedy
club you can do but not this day and age
where all of a sudden then somebody
takes this clip and uploads it to
[ __ ] drunk soccer mom at 4:00 in the
afternoon org and all of a sudden shut
up just drink your way to menopause lady
all right now NOAA ladies ladies you
know fair enough fair a [ __ ] enough oh
you know Dasher and dancer and Prancer
and vixen you know the Capitol Records
building already had their [ __ ]
Christmas tree up before Thanksgiving
I don't know what the [ __ ] they're doing
over there there's just as something
wrong about that you know what about
Tommy [ __ ] Turkey you know it's weird
to say when I was in the grocery store
we were getting our [ __ ] all this
food for this party evidently we're not
having up for the first time ever I
actually looked at a package of turkey
necks and I was like I'd eat that [ __ ]
you know what I mean
it's decent meat what do you how do you
guys how do you guys prepare your turkey
necks use it for a stew all right here
we go let's read a couple more of these
then I'm gonna get on the [ __ ]
treadmill for today you know that's
another good thing you can do in the
morning time right get on a [ __ ]
treadmill knock out a good half hour or
whatever you know just kill the apps
that you're gonna eat today
all right let's let's read the last of
these advertisements here all by the way
thank you for all the well wishes about
me and Nia in our impending Parenthood
very nice you people said a lot of nice
[ __ ] and that doesn't happen a lot on
social media so thank you very much all
right oh here we go everybody oh here we
[ __ ] go it's our old friends we're
giving thanks to one of my favorite
rabbit izing reads of all time right up
there with sharise berries everybody who
is it zip regret zip recruiter are you
hiring do you know where to post your
job to find the best candidates posting
your job at one place isn't enough to
find quality candidates if you find the
perfect hire you need to post your job
to all the top job sites and now you can
with zip recruit or calm you can post
your job to 100 plus jobs job sites
including social media networks like the
Facebook like the Twitter all with the
single click find candidates in any city
or industry nationwide just post once
and watch your qualified candidates roll
into all zip
um I probably spoke up the neighbors
with that one file okay but they're easy
to use interface no juggling emails or
calls to your office do you think Isis
uses this quickly screen candidates or
rate them and hire the right person fast
does this person look like they'd strap
some explosives to themselves they kind
of still got a little bit of Christmas
in their eye all right swipe left find
out today why zip recruiter has been
used by over 1 million businesses and
right now my listeners can post jobs on
zip recruiter phone sip recruiter for
free by going to zip recruited comm / /
that zip recruited comm / / one more
time try it for free it old zip got cop
/ / alright see geek everybody oh Jesus
see key there's a geek in every seat
just like that poor bastard that went to
that Cubs game a long time ago with his
little [ __ ] cassette tape Walkman you
know and he stood up with another [ __ ]
for others Cubs fans but that goddamn
Paul had to hit him and then that
[ __ ] left fielder had to [ __ ]
point it that dude and everybody forgot
about your shortstop and where's that
guy now you know that guy is that guy
was actually the Grizzly man and he got
mauled to death in Alaska thanks to you
cup fence so I hope you enjoyed your
[ __ ] World Series parade alright OKC
geek everybody everybody everything
about see geek is designed to make life
easier for sports fans and music fans
see geek does all the price comparisons
for you by searching multiple ticket
sites and ensuring that you get the best
possible deal see geek does all the work
you just sit back relax and have a
[ __ ] turkeyneck and you save time and
money and Sikhi quants to help you get
the most bang for your buck that's why
every ticket on SeatGeek is given a
grade value of great based on value
you'll immediately see any under priced
seats and be able to find the best deals
that fit your budget best of all my
listeners get $20 $20 rebate off their
first
purchase I want to see Mac Davis baby
baby don't give up on me call to action
must read [ __ ] you it's gonna read it
anyway so tell me what the [ __ ] to do
you [ __ ] putting a capital letters what
are you yelling at me see geeks run by
the [ __ ] bullies alright sit down you
[ __ ] geek alright to get you $20 off
rebate on tickets download the SeatGeek
app go to the settings tab I [ __ ]
hate settings and click add a promo code
and a promo code Bercy keep will send
you $20 off after you've made your first
ticket purchase download the seat geek
app and enter promo code bir today
that's the worst thing an old guy like
me can hear as I'm talking to somebody
younger and they just go okay go into
your settings it's like I'll [ __ ] you go
into the bowels of this device and just
start scrolling and then click on this
and then another window opens up and
then scroll down to this and then do
this and then do that and then in the
end of like okay did that change
anything no no it didn't well that's odd
okay let's try this oh I'm sorry are we
troubleshooting right now am i talking
to somebody in the malaysian islands
trying to troubleshoot my [ __ ] phone
i swear to god half of this [ __ ] i just
want to [ __ ] mail it back i'm telling
you man we should have just quit in like
1995 1995 we had all the technology we
needed all right cars had reared
spoilers you know he had a vcr pc i was
great bc i was great when you didn't
know what DVD was we knew there was no
youtube right people paid for porn it
was a different time it really was you
know that's what these [ __ ]
millennials are gonna be nostalgic about
like lesser technology i have no idea I
should talk you know I don't [ __ ]
know you know you know I've been looking
at lately it's cuz I got the little bit
covenant I want to [ __ ] keep playing
drums in the house so I was thinking
about getting
tronic drumkit you know boy oh boy would
sure be great if somebody hooked me up
with electronic drum kit that I could
promote for free on my podcast look at
me working it yeah [ __ ] that I'm gonna
buy it I'm gonna buy it because if it
sucks I'm gonna tell you if it sucks it
on so I was looking at all these [ __ ]
um electronic drum kits and for my money
rollin makes the best ones they've
always been ahead of everybody else so
they got it this [ __ ] new one that
actually comes with a 22 inch bass drum
that looks like a real acoustic drum I
don't know what the [ __ ] going on with
it and I'm like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] look
at that thing that's the one right there
put your headphones on all the wife
hears is the sound of the sticks hitting
the pads you know that that's [ __ ] it
right there they want [ __ ] 12 grand
for this thing 12 [ __ ] grand
[ __ ] that I'm gonna wait like five years
buy that thing on eBay for like six
hundred bucks
but anyways do you think I don't like
about those electronic kits though is
you sound way better than you really are
and then your ego starts going through
the roof and you're just like how am I
not in a band that already [ __ ] made
it and we all have Grammys and gold
records on the [ __ ] wall and then one
day much to your chagrin you then go
when you sit behind a real kit and you
actually have to produce the [ __ ]
sound and you're like oh yeah that's
right I'm a stand-up comedian I almost
forgot because I've been playing an
electronic kit for so [ __ ] long
however though I did see a demonstration
of the one it's the TD k TD something
rather 50 and then the with the 22 inch
kick and to smell crazy technology is as
I just bitched about it and said it was
you know it was good enough in 1995 when
they didn't even have the mesh head so
the [ __ ] kits it was like hitting the
goddamn [ __ ] brick if you took all
the [ __ ] the whole rebound of the
[ __ ] stick not rebound the whole
[ __ ] shock of the stick hit and you
took it right in your forum anyways this
guy hits the [ __ ] ride cymbal this is
how incredible the technology is and he
just takes the tip of his finger like
you would on a real cymbal and he just
touched it
it's if the vibration gradually went
away just like it would on a real one I
don't know how the [ __ ] they did that he
did it all over this symbol too cuz it
used to be like certain areas you had to
hit the symbol and that would give you
the bell sound or a cowbell sound or you
could choke it but only if you had it
there now you can just do it all over
the symbol it's [ __ ] amazing but 12
grand what the [ __ ] who's that for
I'll tell you who's gonna buy one of
those [ __ ] things one of those Saudi
Arabian [ __ ] oil kits that that
[ __ ] load up that b-52 bomber and fly
all their [ __ ] supercars to Britain
for two months that's what you got to do
if there's any oil kids listen to me
right now you got to buy that $12,000
rolling kit right and you got to have
the same [ __ ] up marriage finish that
you got on your 12 Lamborghinis you know
that gold [ __ ] finish that's that's
so [ __ ] fascinating to me you know
what I mean
that level of gaudiness like you know
you want like it runs the whole gamut
when you go around the [ __ ] world
there's some people like when you go to
Paris it's everything's [ __ ] muted
and then BAM the scarf or the [ __ ]
hat the bag of the shoes but everything
else is the background singer right and
whatever that big [ __ ] thing is
that's the [ __ ] diva the Diana Ross
of your [ __ ] outfit right and then
you go to other areas you go to [ __ ]
Italy some places in the Middle East
Armenians right they're like [ __ ] that
what if we put a group together and
everybody you got Diana Ross you got
Aretha all divas they go all [ __ ]
diva it's a whole other [ __ ] style
the level of confidence you have to have
to pull that off I'll tell you right now
you know can't pull that off you have to
have a certain level of pigment in your
skin to really pull off flashy [ __ ] if
you notice that [ __ ]
the pastier you get to get up to my
[ __ ] ancestors you know what I mean
the colors it gets real [ __ ] limited
forget about when you were a [ __ ]
ginger I mean the amount that the fact
that I actually have a red windscreen on
my [ __ ] it like if there was a picture
of me
now in my pajamas what's what's left of
my red hair you guys watching me talking
into a microphone windscreen to this
podcast again you know what I mean but
if I actually had some pigment you know
I could be sitting here with gold frame
glasses with a gold tooth and a gold
microphone and you'd be like that guy is
the [ __ ] so there you can you know what
hey fair enough fair enough you can pull
it off I can't all right
that's the podcast for this week hey
Happy Thanksgiving everybody and I'm
thankful to each and every one of you
that you listened to my dumb ass every
[ __ ] Monday and Thursday all right
now don't get any too into any arguments
all right you don't want to be that
[ __ ] person all right just sit back
and enjoy everybody else yelling over
politics you know and then you can just
be the cut in the background what about
Joe by Michael Dukakis Grover Cleveland
whatever the [ __ ] you want to yell out
there all right that's it go [ __ ]
yourselves have a nice weekend you [ __ ]
enjoy your goddamn Turkey and egg fair
enough don't get any arguments all right
oh maybe you do and uh let me know how
fair enough worked out how long were you
able how many drinks in we were able to
stick with it before you finally lost
your [ __ ] I want to hear about the
arguments all right send them in okay
[ __ ] you I'll see you
today I hope I find you
so let us trust this time
oh no way
starving
bird
and I could bring it to that I approach
mm
that's not only hold up with clouded
eyes you can see what I care
when I find me throw my face to the face
of the next pretty girl to come by
Thanksgiving Day special Billy Krakow
there's a new one Betty Crocker billy
crocker i like that and i could like to
cook love your intensity when it comes
to bringing something to the table on
thanksgiving absolutely no pun intended
it's it's really a no-brainer get good
at making something and get to a point
where your automatic oh he's talking
about yeah like i was talking about a
few weeks ago when thanksgiving comes
around you got to have that dish that
you just [ __ ] can make and you throw
down and you take it to another level
alright everybody else you'd be doing
the same thing and then the end that's
the thanksgiving meal so this guy goes
yeah you should get a dish down where
your automatic how hard can it be
you'll you'll never been expected to
step out of your skill set if you're
baking breads no one will ever expect
you to bring the cranberry sauce what
you go to this year what's Nia's
specialty what's my go-to this year how
about the whole doing I'll tell you
right now you guys think I'm a [ __ ]
one-trick pony I can make you a turkey
dinner with stuffing mashed potatoes my
gravy game is getting better I got to
work on my gravy game and I know that's
crucial all right but my [ __ ] my
mashed potatoes
not a [ __ ] lump in them all right
enough butter to make you slide off the
chair as they say in New Orleans
that's bad New Orleans accent I admit it
my stuffing go [ __ ] yourself
all right dude you know you don't
understand the recipes that I have
access to all of my recipes start with
melt a stick of butter and 1/3 a cup of
Crisco in a pan okay so you know it's
delicious um yeah my stuffing I don't my
mashed potatoes of this [ __ ] but nee is
african-american so she likes more sweet
potato so I don't I don't think they've
that side respects mashed potatoes
the way they should okay I feel like my
potato my United Colors of Benetton
whatever the [ __ ] it is respect for
sweet potatoes and mashed potatoes I
think I'm a little more mature than the
lovely Nia um what's Nia's specialty
Nia's she's just great at everything
she's one of those people that I'll be
out in the kitchen like this comes out
there and Aikido she's got a couple
things in her arms and I don't know I'm
eating spaghetti or I don't know what
the [ __ ] I'm eating she somehow just
throws it all together or makes some
ridiculous omelet um she's actually a
true cook I'm a little more robotic I'm
um I think I'm gonna become a great cook
or a better cook the way I became a
better comedian where at first I was a
joke writer and I was trapped in my act
and then I learned how to improv and
she's kind of just watching her she kind
of as she cooks she's tasting it and
doing all that type of stuff where I
just they said to leave it in 15 minutes
it's been 15 minutes and I take it out
pies I kind of got the whole thing to
from start to finish my my appetizer
game is terrible in fact I don't even
know if I know how to make one I have no
idea but do I can make a pie from
[ __ ] scratch okay I can look at you
and tell you what all your [ __ ]
problems are as I'm making the pie crust
and not even look down once I can just
feel the texture you know I'm saying
that's how many [ __ ] pies I've made
all right and I'll take that pie some
day and I'll bring it to your [ __ ]
house all right and I'll take a whole
hunk of it just and I'll just shove it
right down your throat and there's
nothing that you're gonna be able to say
other than thank you for that experience
all right as of shaking up the can of
whipped cream to give you a facial
he all of us stop the loud
Willie McCovey on each other
always
hey what's up it's still bar and this is
the Monday morning podcast look at me I
had a little excitement in my voice when
I said that this is the buddy-buddy blow
kiss my voice went up
is it to say I am excited why am i
excited um I don't know I don't know why
maybe because it's Thanksgiving week and
it's a week to give thank you know once
a year
everybody has to sit down and just
really think about why they're so lucky
and just shut the [ __ ] up and give me
some goddamn Turkey I hate that part of
the [ __ ] Thanksgiving where else and
so he's gonna give me a speech like I
don't appreciate what I got you know
just shut up yeah so Thanksgiving it's
Thanksgiving week and it is a week to
give thanks I am thankful I'm just
[ __ ] around and I'm making a turkey
and with some stuffing and I have the
most insane recipe for stuffing that
none of you will be getting during this
podcast because it's a secret family
recipe okay so you have to be part of my
family or be banging me and catch me at
a moment of weakness we have a great
thing of a girl did that you just laying
on your back she's riding you and then
somehow she's so she's so good and bad
she gets you to give away a secret
family recipe he like oh sorry yeah
you're caramelizing onions
27 pieces of white bread what holds it
together it's the egg um all right I'm
literally sitting in my [ __ ] car in
like my Toyota Prius in a parking lot
outside my little offices that I have
out here my little production offices is
I inch my way along on my little
unerring pilot I'm getting ready to
shoot a non airing pilot which basically
means you shoot it and then they look at
it and they go either we like it and
then we want to reshoot it or they go
yeah that's why wasn't airing because
that sucks
so um yeah that's what I got going on in
my [ __ ] life
no this creepy girl just looks like odd
this guy this guy just pulled up next to
me I'm really worried that he's gonna
[ __ ] I put up my windows he'll in
hearing that he's gonna [ __ ] bump his
door into my car which he didn't and
he's kind of I wouldn't say he's really
fat definitely has a Foreman grill yeah
that's nice [ __ ] love handle just hit
my sideview mirror all right oh you know
a lot of people last week broke my balls
and an email kind of way going like you
know cuz I thought that guy rear-ended
me and I good where'd you go check you
know we the most trusting guy in LA you
don't [ __ ] I got a bunch of [ __ ] like
that and it and it's basically because I
figured out what it was told you my
[ __ ] car happened today it was all on
electric and then the car kicks over and
for some reason it gives you a little
push it makes the car lurched forward
I'm really not selling hybrids on these
please [ __ ] podcast cuz I make them
sound like they suck they're actually
there are other damn good cars but
anyways um it is week of Thanksgiving I
like the [ __ ] I'm talking about and my
fingers smell like an orange because I
just ate one yes it's a Monday morning
podcast I do one of these once a week
every Monday to give people something to
laugh about
as they sit in their cubicles as they
drive or [ __ ] run on a treadmill and
if you have any questions that you want
me to answer just email me at bill at
billboard.com or myspace me and yeah if
you have any questions I don't care how
ridiculous it is I will answer the
question like this here's a here's a
here's a nice question question number
one hey Bill I've been a huge fan of
yours since you barely since you were
barely beaten by Rubin started on
American Idol have you ever thought
about giving it another shot
um you know what my time on American
Idol I don't regret any of it I had a I
had a great time you know some of the
numbers that they had us perform like
muskrat love in tie a yellow ribbon yeah
you know I wouldn't trade that for the
world
you know I've moved on and I feel so
much you know I got my sexualities out
there is it did I dream that is it
wasn't on the cover of People magazine
[ __ ] Stan I look like Clay Aiken is
what he's basically saying the sad thing
is that's not the first time I've heard
it
okay you know what you did you just
expose yourself for actually watching
that [ __ ] show what do you think
about that huh I don't need this [ __ ]
you know people supposed to ask me
questions you're not supposed to make me
feel bad about myself like hey you look
like the gay guy who lost we say
could've been it looked like a gay guy
won you know Oh is something wrong with
you Jay yeah it's sucking dick no I'm
kidding
but they do that they definitely do that
you know I learned from some of my gay
friends that a lot of them actually
don't engage in anal they just like now
it hurts I'm like so what do you do and
evidently they just sort of sit around
blowing each other yeah so let's get the
question number two let me see maybe
this one will be a little nicer bill in
my opinion all negative bitter people
all women I'm such a [ __ ] I came to
read here bill in my opinion all
negative bitter people think everybody
everybody are always out to [ __ ] them
maybe that's why you have such a handle
on conspiracy theory am I wrong it's
another guy kind of [ __ ] on me you
know for Thanksgiving week you know you
think there'd be some more thankful
[ __ ] questions how do you ask a
thankful question I just can't how did
you become such a great person got a
thankful question first of all if you're
gonna trash me can you try to actually
work out the grammar so you don't look
like a [ __ ] in my opinion all negative
bitter people think everybody are always
out to get to [ __ ] them all right in my
opinion people who don't use capitals or
punctuation are [ __ ] morons all right
let me reread this so it actually makes
sense okay this guy's opinion of course
he has to let me know is his opinion in
case I thought he had a staff of writers
who write his [ __ ] emails okay all
negative bitter people think about think
everybody is what is this all negative P
bitter people think
everybody now leaves you for you have to
think so [ __ ] up I can't even read it
right here
all negative bitter people think
everybody everybody's out to get their
out to [ __ ] them how about that does
that make sense maybe that's why you're
such a handle on conspiracy theory am I
wrong
ah yes yes you are wrong I'm not a
better person I'm definitely I'm
definitely negative but I don't think
people are out to [ __ ] me like I don't
walk into a bakery and go can I get a
cupcake and when they forget to give me
a napkin I don't go you see I knew it
man um and I think conspiracy theory
gets a bad rap conspiracy theory gets
trashed constantly by people who never
look into conspiracy theory you don't I
mean all they do is they see one guy on
the news who goes there's a guy living
in the moon they're like that's right
there that's conspiracy theory that's
what they that's what they all think
they're they all have conspiracy
theories like that you know I don't I
mean I guess it I don't know I don't
know what to do for you you have to look
at some of the conspiracies that I'm
into and then make your judgment from
there if you think I don't know I can't
judge myself but I mean if you read
about the Federal Reserve if you ever
sit down and do the math on your
mortgage and realize that the bank turns
you into an indentured servant for
[ __ ] 30 years you know do you ever
think about that [ __ ] do the math on
your mortgage
I have a 350 thousand dollar [ __ ]
loan if I take thirty years to pay it
back I pay I give them seven hundred and
sixty-six thousand dollars plus the 80
grand I put down on it so now are we up
to eight hundred and forty thousand
dollars so at the end of my mortgage I
don't be one of those morons go ya know
they [ __ ] please doubled in value
I paid 350 now you didn't stupid you
paid 850 you basically made about 800
bucks in 30 years and now you're 68 what
are you going to do take up water-skiing
it's over it's [ __ ] over you know
and at that point they've devalued the
dollar because they keep pertinent with
no gold behind it which causes inflation
now you can't afford the property tax so
you have to sell it you move out and
they get another 35 year old to move in
bend over to drop his pants and get
[ __ ] in the ass for 30 years and yes I
think that that is a I think that that's
[ __ ] you know does that mean I'm
[ __ ] nuts I probably coming off as
nuts I don't know I'm just saying I
think my conspiracy theories are
thought-out like I feel
whatever they're doing to dogs they're
gonna be doing to us in 10 years all
right and I don't know if you've looked
around but dogs are basically neutered
with microchips in shelters waiting to
be rescued that's what a [ __ ] dog is
now when you were kids remember the
freedom dodge used to have I mean seeing
two dogs [ __ ] in public was a part of
people's childhood and now you know they
can't they can't even [ __ ] anymore
because they've been neutered and that's
what I think they can do with us
microchips you can deal with the
population they're gonna get they're
gonna start fixing people and if I was
on right-wing radio I'd be like that's
exactly what they need that help all
right
that made no sense and I apologize all
right question number two bill are you
worried about becoming too famous well
it's 40 years of age I'm worried about
not becoming famous because I've
invested a lot of time into this I
actually have a cool level of notoriety
I know what you mean I think those
people who are too famous
I think they seek it out I really don't
think the paparazzi is like the CIA and
they have the ability to figure out when
you're going to go to Starbucks without
your panties on I think this there's a
little [ __ ] surf and turf action
going on there you know there's a little
bit of the artist playing up you know
don't they call their publicist you know
I mean yeah I couldn't [ __ ]
I mean I don't know it's just there's
just too many famous [ __ ] people
there's too many places where you can go
like how do they know you're coming from
getting off the airplane at the airport
you ever seen that what happens does the
guy at the sky cat just happened to know
somebody in the paparazzi there's
somebody nodding right now is if they
know and as if they've done it maybe
then okay maybe that happens maybe that
happens a little bit but you know what I
mean
all I know is I look at a guy like Ben
Affleck and Jennifer Lopez and five
years ago when they were dating each
other JLo what they call it Ben flow J
lack what the [ __ ] did they come
Bennifer Bennifer right remember that
you could not get away from it and they
were everywhere and I was like either
they have to kill themselves or I do
because this can't continue to happen
right and then they broke up with each
other and then all of a sudden nobody
gives a [ __ ] about him anymore it's like
I get when two famous people date that
paparazzi swarm all over you but both of
them broke up and then married other
famous people he married that Jennifer
Garner and she married that that creepy
looking guy who's it Julio Iglesias
she married he looks like he looks like
the lion tamer it's not not the blonde
haired one the who though the lion tamer
Siskel and Ebert [ __ ] their name guys
he looks like they want to get grabbed
by the throat yeah Chris Kattan looking
one chris kattan you know if they ever
do the [ __ ] Siegfried and Roy story
Chris Kattan has to play Roy that's all
so that's a meteor part no maybe the
blonde guy is a meteor park as he gets
to cry at his hospital bed like
Fonzarelli when richie cunningham wiped
out on his motorcycle remember that
because if you don't need him I do his
[ __ ] leather jacket was going in and
out because Henry Winkle is crying mom
okay let me get back to the question are
you worried about becoming too famous
yeah I yeah there's a certain level you
don't want to go beyond you
like those guys like whenever I see like
celebrity houses they're like any has
its own tennis court his own [ __ ]
movie theater and people like oh my god
that's awesome and it's like you they
never really think that he has his own
tennis court in its own movie theater
because he kind of has to because he
can't go to he can't he can't go
anywhere so yeah I wouldn't want to get
to that level of fan I would like Steve
Buscemi Fame let's let me saw him at
uggs magazine
I mean Us Magazine I just thinking all
those [ __ ] always wear Uggs US
magazine look last time you saw him an
Us magazine you know wearing a pair of
Uggs going to get some coffee no one
gives a [ __ ] what are you doing I think
you really control it I think your
publicist you know I think as long as
you're not brought up on a murder charge
or you know you're not drinking and
drugging and just making a spectacle
yourself
yeah I don't they think of all the
famous [ __ ] people out there who just
kind of just lived their life you know
what I mean
I've never seen you know Anthony Hopkins
nutsack as he stepped out of a Lexus you
know I mean you just the guy wears
underwear and he's not doing drugs I
mean that's basically it that's how you
stay out of the papers just don't do
interesting things I guess that would
suck but you're famous so you get an
a-level [ __ ] it's all a trade-off all
right let's get over to overrated
underrated and for those you who are new
to my podcast because I just keep
getting new listeners every week we do
this one part of it where people send me
in their list of [ __ ] that they think is
overhead overhead overrated and ship it
is underrated and their reasons why and
I actually am contributing this week
rather than letting my listeners do all
the work I would say uh overrated the
l-shaped couch I'm actually right now
trying to buy some furniture and I've
had an l-shaped couch before and I
didn't realize they suck
basically they sucked because there's no
place to put the TV when you have people
on an l-shaped couch because you got
people there like a diaper
yeah you're perpendicular perpendicular
so where the [ __ ] do you put it
somebody's got to turn their neck and
their necks going to end up hurting and
not to mention it's a very you know
people start drinking you know people's
sight lines start crossing and that's
why that's how guys get in the fight you
know you staring another guy too long
you think somebody's looking at you
least that's what the [ __ ] jack
daniels is telling you you know and next
thing you know you [ __ ] crash land on
the on your IKEA coffee table it's you
know it is the guy you end up getting to
a fight with it's the guy that your
friend brings that you don't even
[ __ ] know him any and the consensus
cut he doesn't know anybody he sits as
far away from everybody as possible and
thinking that that's the submissive
thing to do but it's actually an alpha
male move because now he's looking
across everybody's lines sightlines who
are face forward so Discovery Channel
thing so [ __ ] el-sheikh couches what you
want is a couch and then you want you
want another one of those other couches
the King with the with the thing that
you put your big square thing you put
your feet on that's what the [ __ ] you
want you don't want you don't want to
lazy boy you the lazy boys are also
overrated
they're not comfortable they're not they
suck and all those airplanes now that
have lazy boy first-class seats and like
oh wow yeah that would be great you
could sleep the whole flight just you
know one night go downstairs to your
recliner and spend [ __ ] eight hours
in that thing and let me know how
comfortable that is all right underrated
underrated you know what I actually when
I've got some fast food for a bunch of
people the other night and somebody
actually took the time you know on the
fast food food soda lids they actually
push down the tab to let me know which
one was Cola which one was diet and who
you know who had other and for some
reason it's such a nice thing for
someone to do and nobody does it so fast
food technicians who actually take the
time to push that [ __ ] thing down is
is really underrated and I think they
deserve a raise all right those are
mindful [ __ ] for the week all right and
here's some more people's overrated
friends the TV show is that overrated
I've never really okay a friends is
overrated
I hated the show when it was on and I
can't believe that it's considered good
enough to be syndicated nationally and
aired every day I think this show mostly
appealed to women as I don't know a
single guy that was waiting on the edges
of their couches for the new episode
yeah that's one of those chick shows
there's no reason and I'm sure David
Schwimmer isn't really like that in real
life but uh I just knew every time they
would do a montage of all the friends
you know live their little episodes he
always had to be getting really excited
and jumping up and down like a chick
doing like a falsetto
you know you know and chicks like
something's gonna be exciting and they
jump up and down and clap their hands
I'm or maybe at least TV chicks he would
always be doing that going would and it
just it just made as a guy if you just
wanted to [ __ ] it he just wanted you
know you just wanted something bad to
happen to him
that's what I was always wait boys want
to see the episode with Ross got the
[ __ ] kicked out of him you know
I remember one time going to watch The
Brady Bunch
and uh you know what's-his-face Bobby
did something to Greg and somehow Greg
had orange hair and he actually looked
like he was mad enough that he was going
to beat the [ __ ] out of Bobby and Bobby
was hiding behind Florence Henderson and
you know I remember being a little kid
really wanting to see Bobby get the [ __ ]
kicked out of him like I wanted I really
wanted to see it happen and it's
probably why you know thirty years later
I'm watching the UFC I mean that's the
storyline but I want you know Dennis
thought about that was Greg was actually
sort of banging Florence Henderson right
then I would have Bobby knew Mike Lucan
land
I guess evidently lives in Utah I don't
know why I [ __ ] know that all right
underrated some he said Radiohead some
some of you guys I don't know about
these suggested is Radiohead really
underrated critically acclaimed
everybody like talking about awesome
they're all right this band has been
around for a very long time is yet to
put out an album that would be below
three stars on your four star scale
system whenever I try to talk to people
about them or even to get a group of
people
to go see them play live nobody is
interested at all and no I don't talk
about Radiohead all the time the media
barely ever talks about the band and
when they do they only talk about okay
computer the band's third album this
band deserves a lot more attention and
praise from people as they are one of
the best bands ever formed I got it okay
and I know what you're saying well this
is what you got to look at you know no
matter how good your band is it's never
going to get the attention of some girl
with no panties on or with the titties
hanging out I mean I don't know I'm
probably speaking out of turn here
because I don't have a vagina but it
really just seems like women realize
this and they're just forever showing
their [ __ ] ass and things like even
like girls who are like respectable it's
like now I'm not doing this I'm not
doing booty videos bah bah bah
then they finally get on like a sitcom
or something and the first spread they
do do you know I'm saying they get on
like the little coochie cutters the
[ __ ] who has hanging out you know
they got to fingers the index and middle
finger over both nipples with their
mouth half open like Oh does somebody
want their [ __ ] sucked they always do
like that that photo shoot you know
laying down completely naked and
everything somehow you don't quite see
their ass crack and there's no nipple
but you basically you basically see
their entire body except for the ass
crack and some nipples other than that
you've seen every piece of flesh that's
on them and you know they always do that
and I know that's what I don't
understand women always bitching about
that type of [ __ ] talking about oh you
treat this like sex objects it's like
[ __ ] you every time your careers in
trouble you put on a pair of fuck-me
pumps and you bend over a couch and then
they go the new sizzling pictures of
[ __ ] who's one of these girl
lifestyle do well get back to friends
Jennifer Aniston and i'ma she did that
on Rolling Stone you know one of the
highest selling things ever
I think women should embrace being
treated as sex objects you know what do
you want to be we're not what do you
wanna be known for being like a
meteorologist you know sometimes I
should just stop talking cuz just keep
going and then just get dumber and
dumber I think that even answer that
question all right ah what do we got
else we got a couple other here a couple
others here this guy said last week you
mentioned voting for Ron Paul because of
the Federal Reserve now that's the wrong
one okay okay bill here's a question do
you have a sketch comedy show in the
works also now that randy court culture
is out I never got to say his name what
are your thoughts on Brock Lesnar versus
Fedor and Mac I think I think oh who do
you think will win uh I have no [ __ ]
idea I gotta be honest with you I have
no idea I just know Brock Lesnar was one
of the biggest human beings I've ever
seen his one of his pecs you know it's
it's like just a PEC muscle is the
thickness of my entire torso and the
size like from my neck down of my waist
so I I don't know doesn't have like a
[ __ ] tattoo right between his pecs
it's like a dagger see there a dagger or
one of those Ben Franklin quill pens I
don't know where this I have no idea I
don't know who the [ __ ] is gonna win it
to be honest with you I've been doing a
lot of stand-up and those fights always
come on Saturday nights
I ordered the NHL package so now my
cable bills like [ __ ] 200 bucks a
month and you know what I hate hate
whenever you're the guy hosting the
fight right and you're like again I know
I won't invite six other guys to come
over everybody tosses me [ __ ]
whatever 10 15 bucks and then you know
the fight cost me you know 10 15 or
whatever what happens everybody throws
you crumpled up 20s the end of the night
you stuff in your pocket and you go out
you spend it on gumballs and [ __ ]
raisins and you know toilet paper and
then the bill comes along it's like you
never had that money I don't know why
why can't you just be thankful during
the week of Thanksgiving
you got some free toilet paper while
others always [ __ ] shirt I've ever
seen
picture a lime green Charlie Brown shirt
except is that the zigzag line is just
straight and for some reason you're
wearing it with incidents colo style and
for some reason you're wearing black
slacks with it and then you ran across
the parking lot and sort of a run walk
on the balls of your feet like how
Walter Payton used to maybe trying to
avoid major injury just like him um
anyways let me wrapped up this [ __ ]
podcast because I got some Chiat I have
to go do when I go back into the
building in all my um all right oh where
we can do all the types what type what I
got coming Oh first of all you know I
forgot to do a [ __ ] thing I've got to
at the top of this podcast I was I
wanted to thank Jill Perry from
Aerosmith for calling in uninformed it's
the radio show I do with Joe DeRosa we
had a great time interviewing him and he
was obviously our biggest and coolest
guests we've ever had totally down to
earth and uh you know I don't know it's
pretty [ __ ] awesome to get to
interview somebody who you've been
listening to for the last thirty years
you know so that's what I'm thankful for
this week against giving and I would
also be thankful if people come up to my
show Caroline's the first weekend in
December let's see seven six 54th
December 4th through the seventh I'll be
a Caroline's comedy club on Broadway the
last stop on the uninformed tour with me
and Joe DeRosa with special guest Harris
Stanton who will be hosting and that's
it happy Thanksgiving to everybody thank
you for sending in the questions oh if
you guys can do me a favor if you go to
my website if you're not on it right now
just go to Bill burr calm if you scroll
down on the right hand side you can
actually see where you can sign up for
my email list just because a lot of
times I send out bulletins about being
in Seattle on MySpace and they end up
going to people who live in Albuquerque
if you if you're on my website you
literally just sign up on the the city
that's nearest you so that way you don't
have to get a [ __ ] email from me
every two weeks I just don't to be
spamming people or any of that [ __ ]
so if you sign up on my website you'll
only get bulletin
from me when I'm playing in your area or
if I'm gonna be on TV basically if it's
something that you can either see watch
here or go to it's the only time you'll
get emails all right so that is it thank
you for listening to the podcast I
apologize the last couple weeks of
filming keeps things have been a little
bit lame because I've been I've been
really busy trying to do do some [ __ ]
out here and and that's it so what do I
got next week yeah next week's gonna be
out to do a Sunday night next week there
will be a Sunday night podcast and I'll
be better rested for it alright but I
appreciate you guys sending in the
questions and I'll just keep saying the
same thing over and over again for
another 18 minutes if I don't hang up
alright so you guys all have a good
Thanksgiving and you know and just try
to remember what you have to be thankful
for
alright I'll talk to you next week
Strega to
dear Ana Paula
stop Thole hold and Wahoo's with
powdered eyes you can't see what I care
what I throw my face to the face of the
next good thing
she needed about
thank you everybody
you